في واد وجد فيه سلاما وطمانينه استقر
الانسان ثم زرع وحصد وبنى قريه بيوتها
حجريه هذه القريه لا نرى من جدرانها اليوم
الا مترا او اقل
انها الموصل او الفارعه قديما وتسمى اليوم
الحني في الجهه الجنوبيه من بلدتي منفوحه
والمصانع ارض مطله على ضفاف وادي حنيفه
وعلى مرتفع منها بنيت بلده حجريه بعيدا عن
مجرى السيل قريبه من اراضي زراعيه خصمه
في احدى البلدات القديمه جنوب الرياض اي
جنوب حجر اليمامه قديما ومع الدكتور راشد
ما اسم هذا المكان الاثري هذه هذا المكان
يقال له الحني قديما
والاشارات القديمه التاريخيه تشير الى انه
الفارعه او الموصل قديما قبل اكثر من 1200
عام هذه المنطقه الحني التي الان نجد لها
اثار ضخمه لكنها كثير منها مندفنه الان
هذا احد المجسات المهمه لهذه المنطقه
لتقدم ايضا لنا صوره ما كان سابقا في هذه
في هذه في هذه الحي لماذا سميت
يعتقد الحنين هذه التسميه وردت لي ان
كونها
كونها على جهه الوادي حنيفه المطل عنها
شرقا واتت بشكل منحني يعني في زاويه معينه
من هذا الوادي
كم عمر هذا المبنى يقدر الان تقريبا من
اكثر من 1200 عام يعني البقايا التي وجدت
في هذه المنطقه تدل على انها اخرها احد
القطع العملات القديمه في سنه 127 من
الهجره فاذا بالتالي نجري الى ان هذه
المدينه اكثر من 1300 سنه على وجود تلك
العمله
التي في تلك الفتره نعم وهي بلده تابعه
لحجر اليمامه قديما ولا خارج حجر هذه احد
البلدات الملحقه بحجر اليمامه قديما حجر
اليمامه هي العاصمه المركزيه لمنطقه
اليمامه وتوجد عن هذا المكان تقريبا من
الجهه الشماليه قرابه السبعه والثمانيه
كيلو مترات لكن هذه البلدات القديمه
المتصله بوادي حنيفه وهذه هي احداها وهي
تابعه لبني حنيف نعم اي تابعه قديما لبني
حنيفه وجود بني حنيفه القديم لاستقرار من
الجهات الجنوبيه من هذا المكان يقال له
الحائر القديم التي اشار لها الشعراء ثم
ناتي من الجهه الحائر جنوبا ناتي الى
الشمال فتكون هذه المنطقه وشمال ايضا هذه
المنطقه مناطق اخرى في هذه الجهه ماذا قال
الاعشى شاعر